Okay, so good morning. We are continuing
the Hebrew Bible today.
Um, last class we talked about King
David of Israel
and how he created the Bible the the
project of the Bible in order to create
legitimacy and authority. Okay, and
we're continuing along this theme today.
So,
let's go over the chronology
of the Bible. Okay?
Um, so in the beginning
there was God. Okay, in the Bible his
name is Yahweh.
And he created the world.
And then he created Adam and Eve
in the Garden of Eden.
And
people who take the Bible literally
believe this was about 4,000 BC, okay?
As we know, Adam and Eve, because they
disobeyed
God, they were banished from the Garden
of Eden.
And they had two sons, Cain and Abel,
and then
uh their family start to populate
the
earth.
But then humans start to misbehave. We
went to war, we were greedy,
and so God desired decided to destroy
the world in something called the Great
Flood. And this is story of Noah's Ark.
Remember Noah
uh was beloved by God, so God told him
to build a great ship,
and then he will be able to live. Okay?
Um, after Noah's Ark
um
came along a man named Abraham. And this
is about 2,000 BC.
Abraham was born in the city of of Ur in
Mesopotamia.
And he was beloved by God because he was
a righteous
and decent man.
And God made a covenant with him.
Covenant.
And a covenant is
a contract. It's a promise.
And the contract is this.
If you, Abraham, swear allegiance to me,
Yahweh,
I will make you and your descendants
founders of a great nation called Israel
that will stretch from the Nile to the
Euphrates. That's a promised land.
In return,
uh as a mark of this covenant, Abraham
and his ancestors will uh engage in
circumcision. Okay, basically the
foreskin of their penis will be
surgically surgically removed at birth.
Okay? So, that's the covenant.
Abraham had a son named Isaac.
And Isaac had a son named Jacob.
Okay?
Um Jacob is the younger son of
um Isaac. So, Esau should have inherit
the birthright and the blessing from his
father Isaac. But Jacob played a trick
on Esau and stole the birthright.
Esau was very angry. So, Jacob had to
run away and live with a relative for um
a couple of decades.
And while there, he married two sisters
named
Leah
and Rachel.
And then together,
they had 12 sons.
And these became The 12 sons became the
12 founders of the 12 tribes of Israel.
Jacob will be renamed by God as Israel.
So, Jacob really is the founder of the
nation of Israel.
Jacob Jacob's youngest son is named
Joseph.
And he is beloved by um Jacob so much
that his brothers became jealous of him
and sold him into slavery in Egypt.
Joseph was also beloved by God and he
had a special gift of reading dreams and
he became a special advisor to the
Pharaoh. And he became
very wealthy. Meanwhile,
back in the land of Israel,
Jacob and his sons, their family, are
facing this massive famine.
So, Joseph comes and rescues them and
the entire nation of Israel moves down
to Egypt.
Okay? Where they become very wealthy and
prosperous. And because they have many
children,
eventually, after a couple of decades,
they become a threat
to the establishment. So, the new
Pharaoh, who has no memory of the
contributions of Joseph, enslaves
the Israelites.
And he wants them to die. So, he
basically forbids them to have
uh sons and he um um basically
tries to sanction the Israelites as much
as possible.
Eventually,
a man named Moses
is born into the Israelites in Egypt.
And because he's a boy,
he has to be killed. So, his mother puts
him in a basket
and then this basket drifts down the
Nile and into the hands of the Egyptian
princess.
So, Moses grows up to become um an
Egyptian prince.
But eventually, God informs him of who
he really is and he's the prophet
um who will deliver the Israelites back
into the promised land.
The Pharaoh refuses to let the
Israelites go. There's a major contest
duel between Moses and the Pharaoh,
and then God sends down like 10 plagues,
okay, 10 plagues
to force the Pharaoh to release the
Israelites.
Moses is taking the the Israelites into
the promised land. And then Pharaoh has
a change of heart, and he wants to
destroy the Israelites before they can
escape. So, the Pharaoh chases them.
Moses causes the sea to part. They they
cross the valley, and when Pharaoh and
his army are about to enter the sea, the
sea closes in on them and drowns them.
Okay?
And then when Moses and the Israelites
are in the desert,
Moses ascends a mountain to receive the
law of God. And this is what we call the
10 Commandments.
But while Moses is away,
the Israelites
create an idol to celebrate Yahweh. And
Yahweh hates this, because Yahweh does
not want to be represented on Earth.
So, Yahweh um sentences them to a long
exile in the desert. And he tells Moses,
"You will deliver the people from Egypt,
and that is your mission, but you will
not enter the promised land. You can see
the promised land, but will not enter
the promised land."
So, the mission goes to Joshua, who is
Moses' disciple. And Joshua and the
Israelites start a massive military
campaign into the land of Canaan, which
is a promised land. And over the span of
years, they basically massacre the
people, and they create the nation of
Israel.
And then we enter the period called the
judges. And these are 12 individuals who
become
the tribal leaders of Israel.
And Israel at this time is at war with
all the neighbors, the Moabites, the
the Philistines,
the Canaanites.
Um and this period lasts for a long time
until
the Israelites pick a king named Saul to
lead them.
Okay, King Saul. And then as we know
from King Saul will come David who will
usurp the throne from Saul and be the
great king of Israel that we that we
remember today, okay?
And David is considered the real founder
of the state of Israel as well as the
Jewish faith.
Okay? So, that's the chronology
of the Bible.
Now, because the Bible is written almost
like a historical document,
for most of human history,
people believed this to be literally
true.
Okay?
But in the past 400 years, 300 years,
there have been many archaeologists who
have tried to prove
the events in the Bible. For example,
Noah's Ark. If there really was a flood,
well, there would be a geological
record. There would be a ship.
Okay? There would be a memory of this.
But there was never but we but
we have never been able to found any
concrete evidence to support Noah's
Ark or or okay?
How about the Garden of Eden? Well, if
the Garden of Eden really existed,
well, we could also find it and we've
never been able to find it.
All right?
How about Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob?
Again, no evidence that any of these
individuals ever existed.
How about Moses?
Well, we would think if Moses really did
exist, there would be some records of
him in the Egyptian history, right?
I mean, 10 plagues is a travesty and a
disaster on the Egyptian people.
No record of that.
Uh the parting of the sea, no record of
that. Uh the judges,
uh Joshua, nothing, okay? It's only It
is only until we get to David
when we begin to see historical records
and proof that David actually existed.
But before that,
nothing in the Bible
um has proven to be
um historical.
Okay? And so, this is very confusing.
So, what I will show you today is
if you see the Bible as a historical
record, you will only get confused. If
you see this as as a chronology,
this makes no sense.
If you see this as a work of fiction,
like a lot of people will do, this
doesn't make much sense either, okay?
Because when you read the Bible, these
events aren't actually interconnected
with each other.
David has no memory of Moses, for
example.
That's weird. Moses has no memory of
Abraham.
Okay? So, these stories are not
interconnected.
So, if this is not a historical record,
if this is not a work of pure
fiction,
what is this thing?
Okay? What I will show you today is
this is not a chronology. This is a
cosmology.
Cosmology.
Okay?
You remember last class, we talked about
why
things are written down in the ancient
past. And as I said, kings sponsor
writing projects for three major
reasons.
The first reason is to create legitimacy
and authority.
The second reason is to create a
national identity, cohesion among the
people.
The third reason is the idea of
differentiation.
To tell people who they are not. We're
Israelites, we're not Egyptians. We're
not Canaanites. We're not Philistines.
Okay, so these are the three major
reasons why kings sponsor
writing projects.
And for the Israelites and David, these
three
um
imperatives are particularly salient.
Okay? They're really necessary. All
right? So, let me explain
why that's the case.
So, legitimacy.
Remember,
David usurped the throne from a Saul.
Saul came from a noble family, and he
was elected by the chieftains
to be their king.
And then David launched a rebellion and
eventually usurped the throne.
So, David has a major legitimacy
problem.
So, how he solves the problem, as we
discussed last class, is the Bible
presents him as a poet king.
Okay? This is a very important concept.
Poet king.
There have been warrior kings, right?
People kings who go to war and they win
legitimacy by defeating all their
enemies. There have been priest kings,
kings who are head of a major religion,
but David is the first poet king.
Okay? He writes poetry. He sings songs.
He's a sensitive soul. That's That's
what explains his affair with Bathsheba.
And that that that tells us he could
never have possibly been ambitious and
want to kill Saul. Okay, he's the first
poet king. So, why is he king of Israel?
Because guess what guys,
God is the poet God.
Okay? Poet God. Yahweh is the poet God.
So, this is a radical conception of
divinity in ancient world.
Gods previously have been priests or
warriors. This is the first time in
human history where God Yahweh has been
presented as a poet God. When you read
the Bible, it's very interesting how he
creates the world.
He speaks and things are created.
Okay, he says, "Let there be light.
Let there be heaven and earth."
He speaks and when he speaks, a new
world is created. And then he And then
he looks at the at this world and says,
"And this is good."
Okay? So, he's like a writer who speaks
words and then who edits
his words in order to create something
much more beautiful. He's a poet.
As a poet,
he's very sensitive.
Okay, which means
he creates Adam and Eve because he's
lonely. He wants friendship.
Okay?
So,
in other words, the Bible is
fundamentally a story of friendship, of
two poets who are alone in the world and
who found friendship and comfort in the
exist is in each other.
Okay, and the way the Bible accomplishes
is through the idea of covenant.
So, in the Bible, there are four
covenants, promises. So, the first
covenant
um is between Noah and Yahweh. It's It's
what we call the Noahic covenant.
covenant, the Noahic covenant.
The idea of this is this.
After Yahweh destroys the world, he
feels tremendous remorse for what he's
done. He promises Noah,
"As long as humans are not too evil, I
will not destroy the world, okay? If
humans stay good, I will not destroy the
world."
The second covenant is between Abraham
and Yahweh, and it's called the
Abrahamic
covenant.
And in this covenant,
Yahweh says to Abraham, "If you and your
ancestors, I'm sorry, if you and your
descendants stay true to me, I will
create a great nation out of you."
Yeah, I will give you the nation of
Israel.
The third covenant is between Moses and
Yahweh, and it's called the Mosaic
covenant.
And the idea is,
"If the Israelites
follow
the Ten Commandments
and worship Yahweh, only Yahweh,
then Yahweh will protect them as a
nation.
Yahweh will show them favor, okay?"
So, so those are the three covenants.
But,
when we get to David, called the Davidic
covenant,
something interesting happens.
All three previously are what we call
conditional covenant. If you do this,
then I will do this.
But when when we get to David, it's
unconditional.
"I, Yahweh, will promise that you,
David, and your
descendants will forever rule Israel.
The house of David will forever rule
Israel." Okay? It's an unconditional
covenant that shows his everlasting
friendship with David. In other words,
the Davidic covenant
marks the end of biblical history.
Yahweh, this great God, poor God, who's
been who searched the universe for
friendship,
has now found his great friend in David.
And so his search has ended, and
biblical history has ended.
Okay?
This is a radical new idea in human
history, how a king and a god can be
poets, and how the world how reality
reality can can be constructed through
words.
Okay? And that's why in the Bible,
there's a very famous phrase called, "In
the beginning, there was the word."
And that's why
um
Jewish people are so literary, okay?
Because that's part of the tradition.
If you look at some of the most famous
writers,
and the most some of the most famous
thinkers in the world,
um they're mainly Jewish. And again, a
lot of it is because
um the Jewish faith is the first faith
to focus on literary creation.
Okay?
So that's the idea of legitimacy.
Cohesion.
So cohesion, okay? The second purpose is
great cohesion.
And as we discussed, after the Bronze
Age collapsed,
the land of Canaan was in complete
chaos. You had all these You had all
these different groups within Canaan.
You had uh the nomads from the desert,
okay? The the Bedouin ones. You have the
hill people of Canaan. You have um
refugees from the cities of Canaan
who've been
uh and the cities have been destroyed.
You have Egyptian priests. You have
foreign mercenaries.
And now you have sea peoples, these
Greeks and these other peoples who are
coming into Canaan because they've lost
their lands
um back at home, okay? So you you've got
this very different group of people
together.
They're in competition with other
groups, like the Philistines.
So now they need to create a
national identity
out of all this, right? And that's what
the Bible is doing, guys. Okay?
Remember, there's a concept we learned
that's very important in class called
syncretization, right? Syncretization.
It means when you bring different
religions together and create a
new religion.
So for example, let's just say my god is
Zeus and your god
is Hera.
And I conquer
uh you and I make you part of my people,
okay? So what we do in this instance is
we marry our gods to each other.
So now Zeus is married to Hera and they
have children like Aphrodite and Athena,
okay?
And this is a way to soothe the process
of conquest. Because even though you
I've conquered you, I still have to live
with you, okay?
So we have to blend in our different
cultures.
This is also true for the idea of
genealogy, family history.
Every tribe has a patriarch.
Okay? And the reason why the patriarch
is to to tell the people we've been in
this land for the longest time and
that's why we have legitimacy
and control over this land because we
were here first.
Okay?
Now when tribes get together, they
intermarry, they form alliances, what
they do that's very common is
their ancestors merge together.
And they become sons and fathers of each
other. So as though it's like one family
history. Okay? You take these different
family histories and you merge them into
one line, the same process of
syncretization, okay? So you look at
this instance, Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob.
It's basically three major tribes of
Israel coming together to form one
family history.
In this instance, the most powerful
family is that of Jacob. Because Jacob,
Israel,
gives his name to the new nation of
Israel. Second most important person or
tribe is Abraham. Because he's the
progenitor
of this family, okay? And third will be
Isaac. And in fact, in the Bible, Isaac
receives the the least amount of
attention.
Okay?
But, the signalization process also
helps us explain
Moses.
Because
we've been looking for 100 years and we
have not found any evidence that Moses
ever existed or anyone like Moses
existed in
Egypt, okay?
So, what's Moses doing?
Well, what Moses is doing is explaining
why there are Egyptian priests
in the nation of Israel, right? And why
are priests important?
Because if you're David and you're now
king,
you want to create legitimacy and you
want to create authority. And the best
way you create authority is by
centralizing your power.
Back then, the best and easiest way to
centralize power is by centralizing
religious ritual.
Does that make sense?
So, what he did was this. He created he
made his new capital, Jerusalem,
and he built something called the Temple
of Jerusalem, which became the house of
Yahweh. This is where Yahweh lived. So,
if you wanted to worship Yahweh, and you
had to, because he was your god, you had
to come all the way to to Jerusalem to
offer a sacrifice. And who controlled
the sacrifice process? Priests.
Okay?
And why did the priest sacri- And why
did the priest Egyptian priest why are
they controlling the sacrifice process?
Because they're the ones Moses who led
the people of Israel out of Egypt. The
ones who delivered
the the Israelites into freedom.
Moses is an Egyptian name. It means son
of, okay?
So it's a very common Egyptian name. So
for example, Ramses
means son of Ra.
Okay? So Ramses is a very fa- is a very
famous Egyptian pharaoh. Ramses means
son of Ra, the sun god.
So both Moses and his brother Aaron
these are Egyptian names for Egyptian
priests.
Okay? So David was heavily reliant on
these Egyptian priests in order to
centralize authority.
Also,
the idea of circumcision
it is an ancient Egyptian practice
that priests specialized in.
Right? So if the new law is to be a
member of Israel to be an Israelite
means you have to be get circumcised you
have to circumcise your children
you're going to go to the Egyptian
priests to circumcise your children
because they're good at that and they
know how to do that.
Does that make sense? So by making
circumcision
the major
mark of what it means to be an Israelite
it gives authority and power to these
Egyptian priests.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay?
Um
the judges
what we believe is the judges are these
local heroes
that bring in all the other tribes of
Israel together. Okay? So in other
words, if you are a member of this new
nation
of Israel, you have an entity or an
ancestor within the cosmology of the
Bible.
Okay?
And that's this explains why the history
of Israel is so
convoluted, contradictory, and complex.
Because you're trying
to create a national identity.
Where everyone all
tribes, all everyone is able to
contribute effectively to the creation
of the nation of Israel.
Okay? Any questions before I continue?
Is this clear to you guys?
What's what's going on?
Any other questions?
All right. Now, the last question is
differentiation.
And this is the most important, okay?
Because remember, you have Egyptian
priests
in
Israel.
How do we know they're loyal to Israel
and not to Egypt? Because the Egyptian
priests went to war with the Pharaoh.
We have Canaanites within the state of
Israel. How do we know they're loyal?
Because they went to war with the
Canaanites, okay? So, in the Bible,
what's interesting with the Bible is the
Israelites in the in their history went
to war with everyone, okay? The
Egyptians, the Philistines, the
Canaanites. Went to war with everyone.
Why? Because they had members from every
single
geography and location in that area. And
so, they need to differentiate
themselves. The best way to
differentiate
yourself is by going to war with them.
Does that make sense?
Also by Also, guys, um when you use the
word nation,
um
I have to warn you, this is not the
modern sense, okay? Nation, it's a loose
political affiliation that is fluid.
Today, the nation-state
uh you're Chinese, you're stuck being
Chinese, okay?
But back then,
if you're an Israelite, guess what? You
could walk across the street and become
a Moabite. Okay?
So, the
the idea of identity back then was
extremely loose and fluid.
So,
when we use the term Moabite or
Canaanite, basically we're talking we're
talking about a geographical location
that has some political force.
But it's not a fixed identity.
Okay? The very idea of ethnicity, race,
group identity back then was extremely
fluid, was basically nonexistent.
Okay? So, Israel, the very idea of
Israel, it's a literary creation. The
idea of Israelite, it is a political
creation.
All right? Does that make sense, guys?
Any questions so far?
You got to move on.
Okay?
Are Are Are you clear?
Yeah, no, I get it. Good.
Okay. All right.
All right. So, this explains why the
Bible is structured the way it is.
Okay? But then the question then is, and
this is a important question, is, okay,
you know what? This was standard
cultural practice back then.
Everyone did this
to create
identity.
So, why is it we have the Bible today
and not say other texts from Egypt or
Mesopotamia?
Why is it
that the Bible was able to conquer the
world basically, right? Because you have
2 billion
Christians, you have a billion
um Muslims.
The Bible was able to conquer the world
and capture the imagination of humanity.
And here I want to explain why the Bible
is so powerful.
It was how it was written that made it
so powerful.
Okay? So, last class we talked about the
apology of David, about the Bathsheba
story,
about the Amnon story.
And we believe the person who wrote
those stories are what we call the court
historian.
We have absolutely no idea who he is.
He's basically the official historian of
the court of David, okay? And every
court will have an official historian.
And those stories are good,
but they're not they're not literary,
okay? They're just propaganda and spin.
But the person who wrote
the Bible, especially Genesis,
was a unique literary genius
of the stature of Homer
and Plato and Dante, okay? The person
who wrote the Bible, who first wrote the
Bible, was an incredible literary
genius.
And we call her the Yahwist.
Okay? Why do we call the her the
Yahwist? It's just convention because
she uses um
uh Yahweh as the name of God, and other
writers don't actually use Yahweh as the
name of God, okay? So, so by convention
we call her the Yahwist.
Now, the question then is, who is she?
And we're fairly certain
she is a or it is she, okay?
And as I will show you, we're fairly
certain it's a she because she focuses
not on war,
not on conflict,
but on domestic tragedy and affairs,
childbirth, marriage, love.
And this is unique in human history.
Okay? So, we're fairly confident it's a
she.
There are many who believe she is of the
court of David. The reason why is uh
first of all,
um
what she writes is very favorable to the
court of David.
Also, back then, as you can imagine,
um only arist- aristocratic women had
the privilege of reading and writing,
okay?
She clearly had access to uh the
mythology of Egypt, Mesopotamia, and
Anatolia. She has access to a great
education.
Uh so, we believe she's a princess.
I will further and make the argument
that she must be either the daughter or
the granddaughter of the king of King
David, okay? I would I would I would
make this argument that she has to be
the daughter or the granddaughter of
King David. And the reason why is what
she wrote, and I'll show you what she
wrote. What she wrote was so
controversial and so unique and so
imaginative that the priesthood
could not possibly accept what she did.
If she was just If she was just a priest
or she If she was just an aristocrat of
low birth,
there would There was no way
her writings would become
um
part of the Bible,
okay? So, she must have been someone of
high authority.
And there is actually
a precedent for this. So, so for
example, we know that in about 2000 BC,
this This uh you know, at least
a thousand years before the Yahwists
began to write,
the Sargon of Akkad, who is the first
great empire builder, okay? The first
emperor, basically. And this is someone
that back then, during the time of King
David, everyone knew and worshipped,
okay? King David knew about him, and he
knew about his practices.
When King Sargon of Akkad conquered
Mesopotamia, he appointed his daughter
named
um Enheduanna
to be like the high priestess of the
religion.
But what's interesting about her is
she's a poet.
And she's the first named author in
human history.
Okay, this is 2000 BCE.
She wrote a lot of poetry.
So there is a history, a precedent for
these kings to appoint their daughters
to be the official poet of their nation.
Okay?
So that's what I think
the Jahwist the Yahwist is. But
honestly, we'll never know and it's not
important. Okay? We we just have to know
she was an exceptional literary genius
who made the Bible what it is today.
All right?
So let's go over some
of her literary contributions very
shortly.
And again, because the Bible has been
redacted for about 2,000 years, 3,000
years, we've lost a lot of of her
original writings. Okay?
So I will I will will will analyze a
couple of stories that we know for sure
she wrote. The first is called Adam and
Eve. The second is the story of Jacob
and Rachel. Okay?
All right.
So you think you know the story of Adam
and Eve, but I guarantee you it's wrong.
Okay? I guarantee you even you know the
story of Adam and Eve, it's wrong.
All right. So let's go over the official
or the mainstream understanding of the
story of of Adam and Eve.
God told Adam and Eve, "Listen, this is
the Garden of Eden. It's paradise. You
can do whatever you want. You live
Life is easy. Apples fall from the sky.
Okay? You can pick
tomatoes and carrots from the ground.
Life is easy. It's paradise for you. But
there's one rule and only one rule in
the Garden of Eden.
The rule is, do not eat from
the tree of knowledge of good and evil.
Because it's poisonous.
And of course, Adam and Eve had to
disobey God.
And God became so angry that he banished
Adam and Eve
from the Garden of Eden.
And that was the our act of
disobedience. The first act of
disobedience, our first sin, the
original sin
that
um has doomed us forever until
the redemption of Jesus, right? That's
the story we all know.
The story is completely and utterly
wrong. That's not what it says in the
Bible. Okay?
So,
I'll explain first
what the what the Bible says, and then
and then I'll explain how we can
interpret the story.
Okay.
So,
God
says to Adam and Eve,
don't eat that fruit, okay?
And then Adam and Eve are curious. Why
can't you eat that fruit?
And then Eve meets a serpent
on the ground,
and Eve
and the serpent talk.
And Eve says basically says, we can't
eat that fruit.
And the serpent says,
why?
Eve says, it's poisonous.
The serpent says, no, it's not
poisonous. You're being lied to.
The reason why
Yahweh does not want you to eat from the
fruit is, once you eat it, you will
become like God. Your eyes will open.
You will have the knowledge of good and
evil.
And then Eve gets angry because she
feels manipulated. And she convinces
Adam to eat the fruit as well. So, they
eat the fruit.
And their eyes are open now. They have
knowledge of good and evil.
Yahweh visits them
in the garden,
and he discovers they're hiding from
him.
And
Yahweh commands them to come out, and he
sees right away they're embarrassed
about their nakedness. They're
embarrassed
about being confronted by Yahweh.
So, Yahweh knows they've eaten the
fruit.
Adam says to Yahweh, "It's Eve's fault."
Eve says to Yahweh, "It's the serpent's
fault."
And Yahweh decides to punish all three.
He says to the serpent,
"From now on, you will slither on the
ground, and you'll be hunted by man.
Eve, from now on, you and all your
descendants will suffer the pains of
childbirth.
Childbirth will be an extremely painful
process." And then he says to Adam,
"From now on,
you must sweat
to grow food to feed yourself.
From now on, life will be hardship.
It'll be a a
it will be toil and pain and suffering.
Okay?
And then he does this, okay? This is
very interesting. And this is where the
Bible
demonstrates its genius, okay?
And the Lord God made garments of skins
for the man and his wife and clothed
them.
Then the Lord said, "See, the man has
become like one of us,
knowing good and evil.
And now he might reach out his hand and
take also from the tree of life and live
forever."
Okay?
This is where the Bible is genius.
Because it's telling us
why God is banishing Adam and Eve from
the garden of Eden. It's telling us it's
because there's another tree God didn't
mention to them. It's called the tree of
life.
And it allows you to live forever.
So, why is this a problem?
Well, there are two things that
differentiate God from us humans. The
first thing is God has knowledge of good
and evil.
Second thing is God lives forever.
That's the That's it.
Okay? That's the only difference.
So, if
Adam and Eve now now know good and evil,
if they eat from the tree of life, they
can live forever.
So, God's afraid we'll become like God.
Therefore, to protect the tree of life,
he has to banish us from
the
garden.
Okay?
Yeah?
Excuse me?
Yeah, exactly. Thank you. Okay. What is
good and evil? Okay.
So, this is what the So, this is a
really complicated idea, okay? But But
good and evil does not mean you know God
and you know that
you know Satan. That's That's not what
it means. It means you know what's good
for you and what's bad for you. So, for
example, before I knew good and evil,
I hit this table, okay? I feel pain,
right?
And I'm like, what pain? What is that?
Is that good or is that bad? I don't
know.
So, I do it again.
Okay? And I do it again. I cannot learn
from my mistakes because I can't
differentiate what's good for me and
what's bad for me.
But now I know good and evil. I'm I'm
like, oh, I hit this thing. It's I feel
pain. Therefore, it's evil. Therefore, I
shouldn't do it again.
Therefore, I should avoid this table.
So, knowing good and evil means you have
the capacity to learn and to grow
through a process of self-reflection.
Once you have judgment, once you're able
to differentiate what's good for you and
what's bad for you, you can always grow
as a person.
Does that make sense?
And if you can do this forever
that you have life and live forever, it
means you become God because your
knowledge is now
infinite.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
That's what logic of good and evil is.
The ability to
differentiate for yourself what is good
for you and what is bad for you.
To engage in in a process of reflection
and self-growth.
Okay?
So, God's afraid
that if we continue to grow, we will
become as powerful as
God himself.
Any question Any more questions
before I continue?
Okay. The key line is this. And the Lord
God made garments of skins for the man
and his wife and clothed them. This is
right after he punishes
Adam and Eve. This is right after he
scolds them.
Right?
This is God giving pitying them and
giving them
a present.
This is very strange. This is
paradoxical. Why would God do this?
Okay. There are different ways to
interpret this, but I think this is God
showing remorse
and regret.
Okay? This is a radical idea, but this
is God
saying to Adam and Eve, "I'm sorry for
this." This is God showing remorse and
regret. Why is God showing remorse and
regret?
You show remorse and regret when you do
wrong, right? But what did God do wrong?
What did God do wrong?
Why Why is God in the wrong here?
It's a radical idea, but can you figure
it out?
Okay.
God lied to Adam and Eve.
God said to Adam and Eve, "Do not eat
from this tree because it's poisonous."
Right?
So, imagine this. Imagine
you're my two daughters, okay?
And
you're like 6 or 7 years old.
And you see me at night drinking whiskey
or beer. I'm really happy because I'm
drinking whiskey and beer.
So, you two are curious and you say to
me, "Dad, what What is this?"
And I say, "It's um poison."
And then you're like, "Why are you
drinking poison, Dad?" I'm like, "Well,
because because I'm older than you are.
When you're as old as I am, you can
drink this poison, okay?"
You two are now curious.
Right? You're curious.
Why is
Dad drinking poison?
So, your uncle comes to the house one
day and you ask your uncle, "Hey, is
alcohol poisonous?" Your uncle's like,
"Of course it's not poisonous. What are
you talking about?"
And so, of course, what you two do is
you break into the
uh alcohol cabinet,
right?
And you drink whiskey. And you're very
You become very happy and you throw up.
I come home and I shout at you, "You
guys are terrible. I told you not to
drink that."
Uh go to your room and you're suspended
for a month, okay? You go to your room,
you cry. And then I come knocking and
say, "Hey,
uh do you guys want to go out to
McDonald's and have a hamburger
together.
Do you Do you understand the story?
Because I know I'm in the wrong. I
shouldn't have said to you
alcohol is poisonous.
Okay? I'm being a bad parent.
So, what's remarkable about the story is
it's basically
a domestic
comedy.
Do you understand? This is what happens
among families all the time. This is the
power of the story of Adam and Eve.
It's a domestic comedy. It's something
we can all relate to. It's something we
can all understand.
What's also really powerful about the
story is
God is fallible.
God is has made a terrible mistake.
What's important is this. God
understands he's made a mistake. That's
why he's showing remorse
and regret.
Okay?
So, again, Yahweh he's a poet God. He's
curious about the world. He wants to
have friends.
But he's inexperienced.
He's naive. He's a new father. So, he's
going to make mistakes.
Making mistakes is a process
of growing up. What makes
humans exceptional, what makes humans
unique from animals is our capacity to
make mistakes and to learn from them.
Because we ate from the knowledge of
from the tree of knowledge of good and
evil.
Okay?
Do you see how radical all this is?
These are radical new ideas in human
history.
God is fallible.
What's important is to
understand and admit your mistakes and
grow from them.
Okay?
Okay.
The story continues because now Adam and
Eve are banished from the Garden of
Eden. They have two sons named Cain and
Abel.
Abel
is a shepherd.
Okay?
And
Cain is a farmer. But they both love
God.
They both want the respect and attention
of God.
So,
they present they they they
give presents to God.
Um Abel
um
is a shepherd, so he offers mutton.
Okay? To God.
And then
Cain is a farmer, so he offers
I don't know, like
wheat or vegetables to God.
God tastes both.
And then God's like, "This mutton,
it's tasty. Awesome. Thank you,
uh Abel." And then he eats Cain's
offering, and Cain's very anxious. He's
very excited. And then Cain's like,
and Abel's like,
Oh, sorry. Sorry. And then God Yahweh is
like, "This food sucks, man."
All right?
And this is what it says in the Bible.
The Lord had regard for Abel and his
offering, but for Cain and his offering,
he had no regard.
He hated Cain's present. He loved Abel's
present.
So, Cain was very angry, and his
countenance fell.
The Lord said to Cain, "Why are you
angry? If you do well, will you not be
accepted?"
Okay?
So, again, it's a domestic comedy.
You're my girls. You're my You're my
daughters.
You go to school and you work very hard
on presenting a present to me.
Right?
And I say to one of you, "Oh, this is an
awesome present. Thank you." And I say
to the other, "You suck, man."
Okay? I'm being a bad parent.
God is being a terrible parent, okay?
If you do well,
will you not be accepted?
You suck, man.
The problem isn't me. The problem is
you. You just suck.
Okay?
And of course, what happens next is Cain
kills Abel.
But then what happens next is
interesting because
Yahweh finds out about this and he
banishes
Cain.
And then Cain says to God, "Hey,
if you banish me, people will know
I committed wrong and therefore I will
be killed by other people." Then Yahweh
says to Cain,
"Okay, I'll put a mark
on you, the mark of Cain.
And if anyone touches you, then I will
punish that person. I will protect you
with the mark of Cain."
Okay? And this is again God showing
remorse and regret
for what he's done. Because God knows in
his heart he's in the wrong here.
But what allowed God to
understand he committed wrong is because
Cain argued with him.
Okay?
Cain argued back.
So, this is a radical conception of
faith in the in the Hebrew Bible.
Faith,
love of God, requires you to argue with
God. Because it's only for the process
of argument that God, who's fallible
will learn and grow.
So, when you argue, when you fight back,
you're helping the other person grow.
Okay? Any questions
about this story before I move on?
As you can see, it's a powerful story
that reveals so much
about the idea of faith and justice
and divinity.
Okay?
Any Any more questions before I move on?
Okay. So, again, the Yahwist is a
literary genius. And there are two
things that make her stand out, that
that make her unique in the history of
literature. The first is her economy.
Economy just means using as few words as
possible
to
express as much as possible.
Okay? You can see the story of Adam and
Eve, the story of Cain and Abel, it's
very economical. She's using very few
words, but within these words are a
universe of ideas.
Almost infinite meaning. You can
interpret these stories any way you
want.
Okay?
The second idea is irony.
Irony just means she's funny.
Okay?
If you tell your kids, "Don't eat that
apple. Don't eat that fruit because it's
poisonous." Guess what? Your kids are
going to eat that fruit.
Okay? And then you're going to look like
an idiot because it's not poisonous.
So, it it's ironic.
She's making fun of Yahweh.
She's making fun of the highest
authority in the
Israelite faith.
And again, that's why if she were not
the daughter of David or grand daughter
of David, there's no way this story
would have gone into the Bible, okay?
But it's a great story
that has infinite literary power.
Does that make sense?
The last story I will mention is a story
of
um Rachel and Jacob. It's a very short
story, okay? So, what happens is this.
Jacob runs away from his brother Esau
because Jacob stole Esau's birthright
and blessing.
And
Jacob ends up with relative named Laban.
And Laban has two daughters, Leah and
Rachel. Uh Leah's the eldest, Rachel is
the younger one.
And Jacob falls in love with Rachel
right away. And he says to Laban,
"I will work for you for free for 7
years and then I will want your daughter
Rachel's hand
uh in return for my for my work." And
Laban says, "Well, you're a relative and
it's better for me to give her to you
than to a complete stranger. So, yeah,
okay?" 7 years pass
and there's a wedding between Rachel and
Jacob.
That night
Jacob has sex with a woman. He wakes up
and sees it's not Rachel, it's Leah. He
slept with Leah. He is now married to
Leah.
Then Jacob says to Laban, "You tricked
me."
And then Laban says, "It is the custom
of our
people to marry the firstborn first. We
have to marry Leah off first before we
can marry off Rachel.
If you
continue to work for me for 7 years, I
will give you Rachel as well.
And Jacob agrees.
Okay? So, it's a very short story.
And there's a lot of economy and irony
in the story.
But again, within the short story, there
is a universe of ideas and emotions.
If you're able to think very clearly and
closely about the story, we will
discover
that A,
Rachel and Leah hate each other.
How do we know that?
Because Leah stole
Jacob from Rachel. We can imagine
that when Laban announced that Rachel
would marry Jacob, Leah was very
jealous.
And for 7 years, every night at dinner,
Leah would cry and scream at her father.
How could you embarrass me like this?
I'm your firstborn. Do I mean nothing to
you?
Then we can imagine the family drama and
the comedy, right? Laban's like,
"You know what?
If after 7 years,
Jacob marries Rachel, they're going to
run off together, right? And for the
rest of my life, I'm going to be stuck
with Leah screaming at me and hitting me
in the head
for
the rest of my life, right?
So, he's like, "I need to figure out how
to get out of this deal, right?" So,
that's why he tricks Jacob.
We can also figure out that Rachel and
Jacob love each other. Their love is the
greatest love in the world. Because,
first of all,
Jacob's willing to put up with this crap
for another 7 years in order to be with
Rachel, right? Second of all, Rachel's
willing to wait for Jacob.
She could at any time just run off and
be with someone else, but she's willing
to endure. She's willing to suffer.
Okay?
So, we can imagine
the
entire
family dynamic and history based on just
a few sentences in the Bible. That's the
That's the power of the Yahwist.
Okay? The power The Yahwist, she's
really writing about what it means to be
human. What it means to have a family.
And that's why the Bible endures to this
day. Because there are these powerful
stories in the Bible
that tell us that reveal to us what it
means to be human. What it means to
love. What it means to forgive.
What it means to have family.
And that's why the Bible has inspired
people for thousands of years.
Okay? Because in these stories, you are
part of the writing process. It's
co-creation, okay?
Your meaning
co-creation. Your meaning, your
understanding, interpretation is what
gives life
to these words. There aren't that many
words, but your understanding of these
words is what makes these words powerful
to you.
And again, these stories are unique in
human history.
The story of Adam and Eve is Everyone
knows the story of Adam and Eve.
Okay? Because it's just a powerful
story.
You can also argue
the power of Adam and Eve
is because
it makes us nostalgic
for the ice age, right? You know in the
ice age we were we were an egalitarian
society
where everyone was equal.
And
the Garden of Eden
is
a metaphor, a symbol for that time.
Okay? So it is provoking or activating
our nostalgia for that time. Within each
of us must be that a long lost memory
of a time when we humans were alone in
the world, there weren't that many of
us,
but life
was fairly pleasant, okay?
Food was plentiful.
We were all friends with each other.
We didn't really struggle against each
other. We we didn't struggle against
nature. We were one with nature and with
and with each other.
Okay?
Any any questions?
So who do the Christians believe to have
written
the Bible?
Okay, who do the Christians believe to
have written the Bible? Well, God,
right? This is the exact These are the
words of God.
And so
in uh the Bible
um there are people called prophets.
Prophets.
And
how prophets work is they visit heaven
or they visit by an angel.
And there's one scene where the angel or
God takes a parchment and puts it into
the mouth of the prophet. So the prophet
is speaking every word
that's the direct word of God. Does that
make sense?
Like it it's it's almost like
he's just
a mailman.
I'm God, I put a a in your mouth, you
come back to your earth, and you
basically
uh announce the word of God.
Okay?
So, there are people who believe
God wrote every word, okay? But, this is
only minority of Christians.
Most Christians believe that whoever
wrote the Bible was inspired by God.
That these are um prophets were inspired
by God to write down the truths of God.
But, if you actually try to read the
Bible by yourself, it's impossible.
Okay? Because it's been redacted so many
times. As I explained to you last class,
there are at least four different
sources in the Bible that have been
spliced together randomly.
It's been edited constantly
um over the
centuries.
Okay? But, honestly, no one reads the
Bible in its entirety.
What usually happens is people only read
sections of the Bible.
Most people get their
get understanding of the Bible from
preachers, okay? And preachers will
explain to you what these stories mean,
but they you won't actually have to read
them together.
I mean, does that make sense?
So, what I'm offering you today is not a
scriptural interpretation of the Bible.
I'm offering you a
uh what I call a literary interpretation
of the Bible.
Okay?
Uh any more questions?
Are you guys clear about this?
Okay. So, um
we'll continue this the Bible next
class.
And next class, we will look at the
religion of Zoroastrianism.
Because when the Persian Empire conquers
the world,
Zoroastrianism, their religion, will
start to merge with the Bible, which
creates new ideas.
Okay, that would eventually become the
basis of Christianity.
Okay?